I declare bankruptcy
sometimes I'll start a sentence and I
don't even know us going
I just help I find it along the way I'm
not superstitious but I'm I am a little
stiffness
I love inside jokes but to be a part of
my someday I am Beyonce always it's
never too early for ice cream Jim I like
waking up to the smell of bacon sue me
make friends first make sales second
make love third in no particular order
you know what they say wall me once
strike one
but fool me twice strike three
I understand nothing sweat stuff we all
get there is no such thing as an
appropriate joke that's why it's a joke
we're all homos Homo sapiens would I
rather be feared or loved easy both I
want people to be afraid of how much
they love me
Abraham Lincoln once said that if you're
a racist I will attack you with the
north you don't know me you've just seen
my penis Webster's dictionary defines
wedding as the fusing of two metals with
a hot torch the worst thing about prison
was dig was the Dementors I love my
employees even though I hate one of you
with my car right
don't want to do anything dying it's a
good thing Russia doesn't exist anymore
I knew exactly what to do but in a much
more real sense I had no idea what to do
now you may look around and see two
groups you white-collar blue-collar but
I don't see it that way and you know why
not because I am collar blind it's
Britney [ __ ]
don't miss poopin you know how I be I
have cause it is because I hate him
grief isn't wrong there is such a thing
as good grief this has Charlie Brown
tell him to call me ASAP as possible
well well well how the turntables too
seems awfully mean but sometimes ends
justify the mean crazy world lot of
smells big but bigger heart it's a
pimple fellas everyone being gets them
all the time and she rocks harder than
anyone alive who we're doing
accidentally cross-dressed don't ever
for any reason do anything to anyone for
any reason ever no matter what no matter
where or who or who you were with or or
where you are going or or where you've
been ever for any reason whatsoever I am
running away from my response
feels good
his last name is Christ he's a power
flight he can heal leopards and I know
it's illegal in Pennsylvania but it's
for charity and I consider myself a
grateful and I feel like all my kids
grew up and then they married each other
it's every parent's dream
[Music]
hey guys you know what Santa characters
must know for moral ethical content
right here